serge federbusch ancien candidat du
rassemblement national à la mairie de
paris
bonsoir serge federbusch merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france qu'elle
quel bilan vous portez quel regard vous
portez sur cette journée des gilet jaune
y at il un retour véritablement selon
vous là on a l'impression qu'on prend
lui-même et qu'on recommence d'abord le
gouvernement cherche à nier l'importance
quand il dit qu'il ya mille personnes
qui défie le bon moi j'ai vu beaucoup
plus de gens du côté du 7e
arrondissement et puis surtout on peut
pas prétendre qu'on interpelle de 150
personnes alors que il y à 1000
personnes totale parce que ça voudrait
dire qu'il est interpellé une personne
sur quatre qui est évidemment impossible
d'en qui sous-estiment il y avait un
dispositif policier impressionnant la
place de la concorde et différents
quartiers touchés les champs elysées
était bouclé donc je pense qu'une
certaine fébrilité
en même temps les un peu les errements
qui gêne un peu dans l'évolution du
mouvement par le mouvement d'origine a
continué c'est à dire qu'on voit
effectivement les black blocks et
entendu le tra gauchistes infiltrés qui
arrange le gouvernement bien entendu où
est ce que je crois c'est que la
situation économique qui est un peu mise
sous le boisseau pour l'instant à cause
des raisons sanitaires et le fait que
vont il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui
sont aidés alors pas tout le monde on
voit bien effectivement dans le cas des
les patrons de boîte de nuit
mais bon on fait que de toute façon dès
que l'état ne pourra plus faire face à
cette situation et ça viendra quand même
assez rapidement dans les mois qui
viennent on risque d'y avoir directement
une vraie résurgence du mouvement ce qui
est impressionnant c'est que deux ans
plus tard
ça n'a pas disparu et c'est tout à fait
il est y dans l'histoire sociale de ces
cinquante dernières années
un mouvement qui dure comme ça depuis ie
depuis deux ans quelles que soient les
circonstances et malgré la crise
sanitaire
alors il ya effectivement d'autres
personnes qui ont manifesté aujourd'hui
aux côtés des gilet jaune dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire les patrons
de discothèques et personnels de santé
également ccc cette grogne qui couve
est-ce que ça va s'amplifier selon vous
il ya eu les aides de l'état certes non
révélé patrons de discothèques ça ne
nous aide pas non plus véritablement
entièrement évidemment l'état n'a pas
bon des moyens un fier il ya
actuellement un endettement et dans
l'impression de monnaie de singe par la
banque centrale européenne on va avoir
des petits utilitaires qui risque
d'atteindre les 300 milliards qui est
pratiquement l'équivalent du montant
vous voyez des dépenses publiques ça
veut dire qu'on est dans des
circonstances économiques complètement
aberrante aucun ménage aucune entreprise
de continuer à fonctionner comme ça ça
marche uniquement parce qu'il ya ce
pouvoir de création monétaire me grâce à
la banque centrale européenne mais ça
marchera pas défini mans et l'état ne
peut pas venir au secours de tout le
monde de la même manière donc dès qu'il
ya une corporation qui peut se faire
entendre dans le secteur culturel monter
un bon par exemple le sauvetage des
transports en ile-de-france ont les
tarages de l'argent h de l'argent mais
ça ne durera pas et donc il va y avoir
un enseignement des mécontentements dans
les mois qui viennent c'est sûr et un
moment ou un autre
l'embrasement pour commenter quand en
fait on sera en particulier à l'automne
ou à l'hiver quand on fait les derniers
feux des vacances et tu te fais ton
disparaîtront je pense que le
gouvernement a conscience de sa lé
pouvoir a conscience de ça et c'est bien
pour ça qu'on avait à faire à ce
dispositif de policiers tout à fait
extravagant on regarde le nombre de
manifestants les certains médecins
certains chercheurs d'ailleurs on
critiqué la gestion de la crise la de la
crise sanitaire ils disent que c'est une
gestion de la peur sans véritablement
entrer dans le concret non on est dans
la gestion des crises est ce qu'on
entendait aussi aujourd'hui chez
certains gilet jaune et français ne s'y
retrouvent pas est ce que le
gouvernement a un discours alarmiste
pour masquer justement tous ces
problèmes économiques qui couvrent
effectivement c'est assez pratique de
voir les gens préoccupés à faire des
tests dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
s'ils sont vraiment utiles ou à porter
des masques qui a évité la banque de san
francisco alors que ont fait pas du tout
si c'est utile aux surtout au milieu
ouvert
mais bon ça meubles les esprits ça
détourne l'attention et ça le
gouvernement bon il est embêté
évidemment par la situation parce que ça
la situation connaît vite du coup et
fragile est mauvaise et ils ne peuvent
en aucun cas rare confiné toute la
france parce que sinon ça serait
l'effondrement et d'un autre côté ils
sont des espèces de l'autisme de
diversion avec des petits des annonces
assez alarmiste on annonce aujourd'hui
le nombre de contaminés en permanence on
n'annonce plus jamais le nombre de décès
alors que c'est tout à fait différent en
mars avril parce que le nombre de décès
est très très faible par rapport à ce
qui se passait il ya quatre cinq mois
donc on a un gouvernement qui est un peu
désemparés qui essaie quand même de
tirer parti de la situation pour s'en
sortir bon ben c'est normal mais c'est
un peu son capitaine et tout ça et là
aussi comme pour la situation économique
moi qui savent plus très bien au niveau
que soit il va non y ont fini c'est
vraiment d'accord confiné et à ce moment
là c'est un désastre
et si ça ne l'est pas mais bien leur
discours anxiogènes finalement va être
de plus en plus artificielle et de
mauvaise foi et sa part se retourner
contre eux deux manches serge federbusch
est ce que le pari est gagné pour les
gilet jaune selon vous aujourd'hui pour
marquer justement ce retour moi je crois
que bon ils sont encore très ils sont
encore loin du compte y avait pas
énormément non mais le simple fait qu'il
continue le simple fait qu'il puisse y
avoir de l'anxiété le simple fait que
yelle une ration considérable du nombre
de participants montre qu'effectivement
le pouvoir continuent d'avoir peur et sa
dernière pour décompter
une victoire alors il est évident que il
ya des débordements que les attitudes de
certains vis-à-vis gare est complètement
contre-productif l'idiote et toucha le
gouvernement est bien et fait mentir est
parti aussi mais bon tout mouvement
social a ses hauts et ses bas
et puis ces figures je dirais à bidc
figure dans la droite
merci beaucoup c'est rhj et l'airbus
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france